buena noche es el momento de actualizar
la información económica en france 24 en
español nos acompaña por supuesto
nuestro compañero jorge hurtado jorge
vamos a dedicar esta crónica de economía
a lo que son los vínculos comerciales
entre china y américa latina comencemos
hablando del crecimiento del comercio
entre américa latina y china así es y es
que recientemente la agencia de aduanas
de china reveló unos datos que muestran
el interés de china en la región de
américa latina y el caribe 2021 fue un
año récord para el comercio entre china
y américa latina en total el valor del
comercio registrado fue de 40 450.000
millones de dólares esto en medio de los
problemas de la cadena de suministro y
la crisis generada por la pandemia de
coronavirus la cifra del intercambio
comercial es reflejo de una enorme
complementariedad según algunos expertos
actualmente china es el segundo mayor
socio comercial de la región y el
comercio entre las dos partes aumentó un
41% respecto al año anterior y sobre
este dato a nivel global los
intercambios de china crecieron más que
la unión europea e inclusive
de eeuu pero como inicio el interés de
china en la región se lo preguntamos a
alejandro godoy él es especialista en
asuntos de asia y medio oriente y esto
nos dijo sheen empezó un proceso muy
grande de crecimiento y en los últimos
30 años sacando a más de 600 millones de
personas de la pobreza y cuando se saca
a personas de la pobreza que necesita
necesita alimentos necesita materias
primas los cuales aquí en américa
latina' los tenemos en cantidad y
precisamente alrededor del año
2008-2009 es cuando se da una primera ya
me moló entre comillas luna de miel de
china con naciones como brasil al cual
le ha vendido una cantidad impresionante
de alimentos chile ha ganado mucho
también porque tiene unas reservas como
bien se sabe probadas inmensas de cobre
venezuela también un socio importante en
el tema del petróleo ha sido fundamental
argentina en el tema de los cárnicos de
igual manera y otras naciones que al
inicio no se acercaron tanto pero que
hoy por hoy tienen unas importantes
inversiones como colombia que el tema
del metro de ir a capital de bogotá o un
proyecto de tren de cercanías también
van a estar financiados con capitales
chinos por ende hoy ya tiene una
presencia sólida en toda la región ahora
va jorge una pregunta que surge no es
mientras tiene a va ganando terreno en
la región como se ve beneficiada américa
latina' bueno es un tema complejo porque
a pesar del beneficio económica que
podría traer esta relación algunos
expertos piden ver con cautela los
compromisos que se asumen a raíz de la
misma en 2021 las exportaciones
latinoamericanas a china alcanzaron un
valor de 222 mil 582 millones de dólares
eso representó un incremento del 31,4
por ciento respecto al año anterior para
los analistas américa latina' ve en
china la oportunidad que otros no
ofrecen y eso le ha permitido ganar
mucho terreno la base de datos de
financiación entre china y la región de
la organización de dialogo muestra que
el volumen de préstamos de los bancos
políticos y comerciales de china a casi
todos los gobiernos y empresas estatales
de américa latina y el caribe la
expansión está vinculada al megaproyecto
la franja y la ruta que invoca a la
antigua ruta de la seda nuestro invitado
nos explica como sin embargo en el año
2013 como recordamos xi jinping isuela
anuncio de este proyecto de la franja de
la ruta que tiene un componente
terrestre que emula mucho a la primera
ruta de un componente marítimo que tiene
que ver también con los puertos y con
ciertos aspectos comerciales de todo el
planeta su proyecto supremamente
ambicioso porque va hasta el año 2000 49
tiene un costo aproximado de 900 mil
millones de dólares y son las
expectativas que tiene en el caso
particular con américa latina' de 1
alejar a las naciones que aún reconocen
a taiwán y que no tienen relación
directa de a nivel diplomático con la
república popular china el vimos el caso
de nicaragua hace un par de semanas
vimos que lo que china utiliza también
como la diplomacia de las vacunas con el
caso particular de paraguay de igual
manera en decirle bueno
con dejen de reconocer a taiwán y
nosotros les haremos unas donaciones
importantes de vacunas bueno jorge
interesantísima de la crónica sobre los
vínculos comerciales entre china y
américa latina muchísimas gracias a
nuestra audiencia y le invitamos a que
sigan informando se en france 24 y por
supuesto en france mit y cuatro.com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]